you know Pythagorean theorem C squared
equals a squared plus B squared right
basically if you have a right triangle
this leg squared plus this leg squared
equals the hypotenuse squared but what
would happen if this side here the
hypotenuse is the longest side if it got
even longer what would it do to the
triangle well you can see it's going to
actually open that angle up it's
actually gonna make this from a right
angle to an obtuse angle so you can see
if the C side the longest side that C
squared is greater than a squared plus B
squared this is going to be obtuse now
what would happen you think if the sea
side got shorter like we pulled in those
two two legs well then this angle across
from that side is going to become
smaller than ninety it's going to be an
acute triangle and of course if it's
equal then we know it's a right triangle
meaning it has a ninety degree angle so
my next question is is if we're given
the three sides five twelve and fourteen
how do we know which is the a B and C
well basically the a is the shortest
side B is the medium and C is the
longest side but what's different here
is that normally when we do Pythagorean
theorem its flipped it's a squared plus
B squared equals C squared it's easier
to work with it in this fashion where
you have the the C side on the left so
14 squared does that equal is it less
than or greater than a squared plus B
squared let's simplify this this is 12
plus 144 14 squared is 196 if I add
these together I get 169 and you can see
that 196 is actually greater than 169
that means that this is an obtuse
triangle okay so you're with me so far
now let's go to example number two we've
got seven eight and ten so again a B and
C C is the longest side so I've got 10
squared question mark 7 squared plus 8
squared so we've got 149 plus 64 so
let's see that's gonna be a hundred and
thirteen right so let's see hmm let's
see a hundred is less than 113 that
means that this is an acute triangle
right acute meaning that all the angles
are less than 90 degrees and then this
one here a B and C this is actually a
trick question now you're probably
wondering hmm Mario why'd you throw this
trick question in here sometimes your
teacher will do this to you but you see
how these two sides are not greater than
the third side this is getting into
triangle inequality theorem you can
check out the video I did on that but
basically what it is is imagine if this
side is 5 and imagine if this side is 2
and this side is 3 it just barely
reaches so this triangle is folding flat
it's like a drawbridge you know you want
some space in there like a for example
if this was 5 and this was like 3 and
this was like 3 that's 6 we have more
than enough room to span that distance
of 5 so what you want to make sure is is
that any two sides added together have
to be more than the third side not equal
to not less than but they have to add up
to more than the third side so